So far we've defined
work in one dimension.
But let's consider
the path of a particle
in more than one dimension.
And on this screen it looks
like a two-dimensional path,
and here's our particle.
And what we'd like to do is
define the concept of work
for this type of path.
Now let's say that
at this instant
our particle is
experiencing a force F.
And the particle is being
displaced by a distance, ds,
which is always
tangent to the path.
And what we'd like to do
now is talk about the work
done for this particle.
Now what we'd like
to first say is
what we're going to do
is imagine that we're
going to break the
path down into a bunch
of small intervals.
And let's call
this the j-th point
and the j-th plus 1 point.
Then our particle
will start at j
and we'll displace it
delta sj to the j-th
plus 1 position on the path.
And here, let's denote
the force by Fj.
And now what we'd like
to do is define the work
for this particular section.
Now our concept of
work is the force
in the direction of
the displacement.
So what I'd like to do is I'd
like to define the quantity Fj,
and I put a little parentheses
upstairs-- parallel lines
upstairs.
This is the component
of the force Fj
in the direction of delta sj.
Now the way we denote
that is we can then
say that if I take the dot
product of Fj dot delta sj,
this is the component
of the force
in the direction of the motion.
Because remember,
our dot product,
if we call this
angle theta j, is
taking how much of one
vector is in the direction
of the other times the
magnitude of that displacement.
And again, when we write that
component in our notation,
if we call this
angle theta j, we
know that that's the magnitude
of Fj times sine of-- cosine
of theta j.
Now because this is
the amount of force
in the direction of
the motion, that's
how we've defined work done.
And we'll symbolize
the work done
in taking the particle from j
to j plus 1 by the symbol Wj.
And now, this is
a scalar quantity.
And when we want to find
the total work, what
we have to add up is
from some initial point
to some final
point, how much work
is being done in
taking our particle
from the initial position
to the final position.
And it's just the sum for all
of these j's, and let's say
we have n of them of Wj.
And right now we're
going to call this W,
it's just that scalar
sum, And, that's
equal to the sum j goes from
1 to n of Fj dot delta sj.
So now we'll use the
vector dot product
because we already know that
this is how much of the force
is in the direction
of the motion.
However, this answer depends on
how fine we broke up this path.
And what we've
seen many times now
is that the actual work that
we want, let's write this as n
because it depends on
the number of paths,
is the limit as n goes to
infinity of this sum of scalar
amounts of work.
Now when we take that limit,
as n goes to infinity,
of this sum, j equals 1
to n of Fj dot delta sj,
this quantity is formerly what
we mean by a line integral.
And we denote that
with a new notation.
We'll denote a line from
our initial to final
and it's a dot product
of the force dotted
into the small displacement.
Now whenever we see the
dot product in an integral
that distinguishes it
from a normal integral,
and this is what we
call a line integral.
Now again, why did we switch
from our delta s's to ds's?
Because when we take the
limit, as n goes to infinity,
our grid becomes
finer, and finer,
and finer until we're
shrinking down to a point
where we can just talk about the
differential displacement, ds,
and the force acting on a point.
And that's what our
line integral is.
Now, what we'll
learn next is how
to calculate this line
integral for a number
of important physical
examples that occur
in our interest in mechanics.